the floods that submerged most of
Nigeria's Coastal communities between
August and October destroyed tens of
thousands of hectares of farmland
but agriculture authorities say the
torrential rains have left behind Rich
allevial deposits and moisture which has
improved the quality of the soil and
that's what tasiusabo is hoping will
boost his Maize Harvest
we got free season fertilizers if this
crop fails we could be in serious
trouble it will determine whether we
survive or starve before the planting
season
the government is providing small-scale
Farmers like taxi with fertilizer and
improved maturing seeds
for the house to use the residual
moisture and and plant crops and also
the good houses out of it
but there isn't enough to go around
officials admit only a fraction of the
hundreds of thousands of farmers
affected by the floods earlier this year
will benefit from a government
initiative to help them take advantage
of the residual moisture left behind by
the floods which means many of them now
in debt face an uncertain future having
lost income and access to food
the government has yet to determine the
extent of damage
economies say the annual losses floods
Coast to Nigeria's agricultural industry
are unsustainable
all the more reason they say why farmers
should move from rainfed agriculture to
irrigation